peu
[Musique]
ouais sur la route entre nanciers
mirecourt juste avant d'arriver dans les
vosges assure la doite toi il ya une
colline une colline lieu simple lieu de
pèlerinage sion de connexion est sis aux
émissions et bien pis au pied de la
colline n'ont rien trouvé du pétrole
miracle dans le temps on allait chercher
le pardon à sion maintenant on cherche
et les sensations c'est qui qui aurait
cru ce pacte du pétrole alors un titre
encore je sais on ne pompe pas encore
pas tout ce qu'on voudrait pour
l'instant on ne fait que 3 litre et demi
par jour je sais ça ne paie encore pas
la peau mais ça fera bientôt pour les
briquets les briquets kg 1 parce que les
étrangers qui travaillent par ici ils
devront encore d'acheter des allumettes
tu te rends compte de les sensations ce
qui aurait cru ça ça va faire du bien ça
va ramener du monde
je sais qu'ils ont déjà fait une boîte
de nuit là m'a parfaitement à sion une
boîte de nuit te sais comment que ça
s'appelle la buée la buée parce que
c'est la condensation au titre encore du
pétrole en lorraine la lorraine sauve la
france de la crise écrit que c'est cris
qui aurait cru ça on a en cause parce
que pour peu qu'ils aient une puissance
étrangère qui viennent nous l'apprendre
mais pétrole dit c'est prévu regardez
ces gardés par la troupe d'une nouvelle
recrue entraîné exprès des
recrudescences qui sont là jour et nuit
ils dorment là sur place bien dans
l'abri des tentations aa titre en compte
bien nous donner les plus forts du
pétrole en lorraine qui courait que ça
qu'on allait trouver ça on trouve sous
le sous sol ont tout du pétrole autour
de l'essence ont cours de l'huile pour
peu qu'on trouve de l'air comprimé du
chewing gum et des lunettes de soleil
tout à la belle station service qu'on va
faire et puis si on en a trop du pétrole
tu sais ce qu'on fera on en boira déjà
qu'on pète le feu alors que le
gouvernement nous prenne au sérieux et
viennent nous aider parce qu'on n'est
pas assez pour extraire je pense là bas
tu sais combien qui sont au fond puis 11
11 pipe thor qui aura constipation
il y aura pas de débouchés alors tu sais
ce qu'ils disent gouvernement et duos en
fout le pétrole en france on a pas
besoin
on n'a pas besoin de l' or noir on alors
vers en a c'est sûr car en france on
alors v on à l'envers de la médaille
louis claude vanony bonjour bonjour vous
ne cachez pas vos origines vosgienne et
vous avez bien raison et est ce que ça
vous gêne si on vous qualifie de comics
vosgien pas du tout puisque c'est vrai
bonhomme voilà costumes bogeys pour les
textes sont petites plus toujours
vosgien mais enfin j'ai gardé l'accent
et puis le bol ont taillé dans la masse
et les textes je suppose que c'est vous
qui les écrit mais voilà avec beaucoup
de mal d'ailleurs
faut pas dire ça comment vous avez eu
l'idée de faire un numéro un tour de
chant un tour de comics projet pas eu
l'idée j'ai toujours eu envie de faire
rire mais mes amis
depuis tout le temps depuis tout petits
à l'école maternelle
après dans les autres classes à puis
après j'ai travaillé que le groupe
folklorique des ménestrels à gérardmer
et puis voilà c'est parti comme qu'est
ce qui vous fait dire et comme vous êtes
jeune quand vous étiez grâce tout me
fait rire moi je suis très bon public
moi je j'éclate de rire
même trop d'ailleurs c'est dans une
salle de spectacle on sait où je suis
est-ce que vous avez un grand ancêtre
est ce qu'il y avait un conteur célèbre
dans les vosges lorraine y avait hors
jeu super bien sûr vivre la communion du
gamin on retrouve parmi les gros
monument ça ça m'a bien fait rire je
racontais ça moi-même à la communion
quand j'étais petit les textes de
georges sait faire le chapeau joue un
rôle important
bah oui parce que dans le temps on avait
tout ça chapeau comme ça et puis
maintenant c'est un petit peu partie
servia je crois on a dit que pour la
mode ça allait revenir leshop ch ou
alors vous peignez les vosgiens vous les
caricaturer un petit peu qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont deux spéciales les vosgiens
au son comme tous les paysans de france
et du monde entier c'est des gens qui
prennent le temps de vivre c'est des
gens qui sont encore vrai qu'ils sont
sincères et qui sont un peu un peu
bourru un peu tonia comme on dit chez
nous mais qui sont vraies c'est dix se
dit vous dites qu'ils prennent le temps
de vivre je crois même qu'ils vivent
longtemps et que le troisième âge ça
vous a jamais dit quelque chose
mon pauvre monsieur inquiète venir à
gérardmer je vais vous en cause aller
raconter mon cerveau ça le troisième âge
alors là je peux t'en causé à gérardmer
je sais pas c'est quoi si c'est l'air ou
autre chose mais non non mais elles ont
fait partie du troisième âge à le
retenir et ma mère 75 ans c'est reparti
comme en 14
elle a retrouvé un petit copain elle
drague elle va refaire sa communion la
12e bien sûr elle va à la piscine de
mercredi est elle n'agit que sur un pied
un mais elle fait du chemin quand même
et puis elle va l'entraînement elle fait
comment qu'elle a dit jah puisqu'elle
disait du karaté l'autre jour elle est
rentrée de l'entraînement il y avait le
moniteur qui la suivait le moniteur il
avait un oeil comme ça ma mère elle a
dit je ne sais pas c'est qui qu'a raté
mais moi je les ai pas loupé tué ma mère
75 ans les yeux de chez nous ils
rigolent passé ou qui vont les vieux
chez nous à la maison des jeunes
alors ils jouent du théâtre tout sauter
mais moi j'ai été invité puisque c'est
ma mère
normal puisque je suis son fils alors j
ai dit qu'est ce qu'ils vont jouer les
yeux là ils vont jouer quoi le range la
visite de la vieille dame temps fou que
c'est ce qu'ils ont joué la fièvre du
samedi soir
enfin il est alors temps sur ma mère
elle sait se défendre
faut pas venir la chicane et parce qu'il
ya des voyous qui attaquent des fois les
personnes du troisième âge alors ma mère
je préviens tout de suite avec ma mère
orange mécanique avec ma mère ça marche
pas mal mais c'est après ça que
humain l'autre jour il ya un noyau qui a
voulu attaquer ma mère et ben mon vieux
elle lui a fait une clé au cou deux clés
au bras trois clés à la jarne c'est le
serrurier qu'avenue démêler tout ça
parce que la municipalité chez nous ils
ont bien fait les choses ils ont donné
aux personnes du troisième âge des
sifflets comme ça les personnes du
troisième âge dois-tu elles se font
attaquer alors elle siffle comme ça les
wayuu il en peur il sa revanche
les gendarmes disent arrive hein quoi
des fois c'est le contraire
l'autre jour il ya un voyou qui voulait
attaquer qui voulait attaquer ma mère
lui avait pris son sac à main
ma mère m'aime mais voulez vous lâcher
moissac espèce de petit voyou
oui ou lâches et mansac oui ou non mais
où les ou l'arraché bon sac ou alors
laissez moi le temps de prendre nos
sifflets les tirs on va mettre le
sifflet dans le sac aux enfants des
belles et pillages et voyons je te
verrai où ceux qui vont aller à nice qui
vont aller à bientôt
alors ma mère elle a dit comme ça mais
si on va à nice faudrait peut-être que
je me rachète un nouveau maillot de bain
puis dit oui maman mais à 75 ans quand
même tu ne peux pas te jeter n'importe
quel maillot de bain achète toi un
maillot une pièce elle m'a écouté
acheter que le bas la santé mam et à
bastien l'autre jour heureusement
qu'elle a de l'entraînement parce que le
jour était dans le car tout appui comme
elle a un peu chez ftn tout ça elle
avait le micro du chauffeur et puis elle
était dans l'allée centrale doit le car
au milieu ne peux pas te tromper en a
qu'une et pis elle cause est comme ça et
puis elle tentera d'expliquer qu'en fait
pipi à 3h30 corps montrés d'alc à 15h45
tchad à coup je sais pas ce qui a eu le
car qui ralentit un peu brusquement ma
mère père le calibre là voilà qui part
en arrière double saut périlleux arrière
vriet elle passe au travers du
pare-brise le car ne s'arrête pas le
passé entre les roues elle remonte par
la porte de derrière elle avait pas
lâcher le micro on a même profité pour
dire au chauffeur
vous avez une petite fuite d'huile au
port hier mais heureusement qu'elle a de
l'entraînement elle nous surprendra
toujours
l'autre jour quand il dans la salle à
manger pour lui dire bonjour et puis
depuis le couloir la porte était ouverte
aux et du déballage nishi celle des
draps démons mais qu'est ce qu'un préfet
évincé son trousseau où bien
réparé les rideaux du salon elle pliait
son parachute
elle avait cours à 3 heures cette
rencontre ma mère est bien en vélo la
rattrape pas mam et en vélo et l'a fait
à 75 ans le ballon d'alsace l'otsc ou en
vélo tu te rends compte le ballon
d'alsace oui môssieur le ballon quand
elle a redescendu les gendarmes
voulaient qu'elle souffle dans le ballon
et l'a dit merci j'en sors tu te rends
compte ma mère le ballon d'alsace aller
retour en vélo à 75 ans qu'est-ce
qu'elle s'est fait attraper en rentrant
par sa mère sa mère attendait le vélo
pour aller au quatrième au genre claude
vanony est-ce que vous menez votre
carrière comme n'importe quel artiste du
show business ou es ce que vous avez une
carrière un peu particulière d'abord le
chauve business moi j'ai un truc que
j'aime pas trop je me considère comme un
artisan du spectacle j'aime le travail
bien fait et puis voilà comme ça c'est à
dire que vous ne songez pas faire
l'olympia un jour assis pourquoi pas si
on me le demande si ça peut se faire
bien sûr mais pour l'instant ça ne me
semble pas une nécessité c'est surtout
pas un but mais si un jour je peux faire
le lendemain je le préfère le friant
monsieur penser que j'irais bien vous
faites des disques en effet combien
bagéens de sortir le septième 30 cm
alors vous avez des fidèles
oui heureusement mais je les en remercie
est ce que vous faites des tournées en
dehors des vosges oui sur la gt sa voix
en haute savoie j'ai été dans le
tarn-et-garonne là je vais aller dans le
nord
là je repars dans l'isère bientôt vous
avez parlé des défauts des vosgiens
enfin gentiment est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire quelles sont leurs qualités au
lors quelle illusion dont beaucoup comme
tous les paysans ce sont des
travailleurs sont des gens qui se tuent
au travail ce sont des gens qui aiment
les choses bien faites ce sont des gens
qui sont droit sont des gens qui sont
pure oui c'est vrai je le pense ils ont
le sens de l'économie aussi jeu à fond
rien gâcher au il faut rien gâcher mon
pauvre monsieur surtout à l'époque du
jour d'aujourd'hui
racontez-nous ça il faut rien à cacher
parce que je jouais alors là les
vosgiens on est bien placé pour savoir
faut rien lâcher on hajjarian l'essence
les sens qu'on dit que l'aah augmenté de
pense nous on est débrouillard il entend
qu'on connaît le truc l'essence et la
prog menthe et moi j'en prends toujours
prouvé en france beaucoup de pop le
cheikh guèye et un truc que j'ai fait je
vais vous le dire puisqu'on est dans
l'intimité
j'ai trafic et mon tracteur et au lieu
de le faire marcher à l'essence mon
tracteur je le fais marcher à la
mirabelle coûte moins cher maintenant un
lit de mirabel parce que c'est moi qui
le fais seulement quand tombe en panne
des fois le carburateur faut le débouché
alors le gicleur il faut jamais
essoufflé il faut aspirer artisans quand
tu te bats pas d'une paire de fois dans
la journée
mais attention vous jamais conduire ton
tracteurs en réparation chez le
mécanicien
quand tu as fini de faire le plein parce
que c'est plus le tracteur qu'il faut
réparer c'est le mécanicien en forêt a
gâché aubin on se demandait comment
qu'on allait faire pour chauffer pour
éclairer chez nous ben l'éclairage on a
trouvé le truc on a mis grand-père
accord c'est une dynamo ses grands pères
qui pédalent tweb l hiver quand on joue
aux cartes un os à la lumière qui baisse
on va lui resservir à canon c'est parti
on peut finir le mille
ben le chauffeur on se demandait comment
on allait chauffer avec le soleil ou
bien avec d'edf net c'est chez nous dans
les vosges
le soleil fait plus souvent grève que
d'edf
alors on a déjà supprimé la couverture
chauffante
parce que ça c'est raide comme tout la
couverture chauffante tu te retrouves le
matin avec les skis m'offrant du dans le
pyjama et puis on a mis deux lits un
grand lit pour les yeux un grand lit
pour un jeune eva les jeunes ils ont
encore trop chaud parce que la nuit on
il faut du var avec des couvertures
il faut rien gâcher ma belle mère ma
belle mère et cette mise dans l'idée
de s'acheter un dentier j'aime bien ma
belle-mère ont marqué la des sous c'est
pas une raison pour les dépenses et les
souks est-ce qu'on deviendra nous plus
tard un dentier lui dû me voir qu'elles
en avaient besoin les dentiers parce que
j'ai pas dit non le château du
haut-koenigsbourg thouet les créneaux un
coup je te vois un coup je te vois plus
la même la bouche en piano quoi une
blanche noir une blanche n'a pas dit
quand elle monte dans une pompe envoyer
ou qu'elle passait lui un dentier non tu
prenais une bien m'en sers pour rappel
une petite contente mon vieux elle était
tellement contente qu'elle criait sa
joie au monde entier tiens l'autre jour
c'est pas le moment de se laisser faire
non plus par les commerçants l'autre
jour on avait été faire du bois avec les
copains puis on rentre on avait soif tu
es bien je vais à la coop est parce
qu'on l'a encore une coop est nous je
vais encore pète j'ai dû aller chercher
un lit tu es pour changer et j'y tiens
me prend dans l'it de blanc ils me
donnent un lip dub l'enduro refléxion
fait j'aimerais presqu'autant mieux du
rouge
j'ordonne leblanc il me redonne nous
jamais à huawei est même dit on mais
vous n'avez pas payé votre clique de
rouge fluo mais je vous ai donné le
blanc à la place
mendil blanc ou l'aviez pas payer non
plus sinon mais je l'avais pas vue pour
rien gâcher mon vieux port ya danger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]